foreign
[Music]
good thing we got toy here today because
Papa John's just debuted it's brand new
food item did you guys hear about it
calzone no oh you think it's a calzone
fish sauce wait till you hear what this
is is it a meatball sub
I no it's not a meatball sub it's
arguably worse they got something called
the crustless pizza what
that's just cheesy bread dude oh you
think it's cheesy bread that's just
cheesy bread dude no that's Pizza it's a
crustless pizza how are you gonna hold
it but there's still dough underneath oh
it's like crustables but pizza now wow
it's like a deconstructed Pizza Bowl
with no bread involved whatsoever oh no
like a salad oh thank you that's what
everybody's calling it they're all going
they're going that's a salad that's
exactly is it so there's no bread at all
under it no bread anywhere it's
everything but the bread just in a in a
little bowl when you say crustless I
thought it was just no Rim Yeah that's
what I thought too I thought it was like
a flatbread or something no anything no
bread at all so it's ingredients it's
ingredients just make your own pizza
toppings so it's accessories just just
toppings yeah so is this for keto cheese
like is it in later I don't know who
it's for it's for nobody dude because
nobody goes that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks
he was just mad dog and it's so hard you
know what that is it's a pasta-less
lasagna
so it's useless that's what it is
because it's just it's just cheese
tomato sauce and toppings you think
somebody was like look dude people are
just eating the inside and leaving the
crust and then they decided to take out
all the breakfast little kids doing that
really know about like people who are
like half cheating on their Atkins or
something try to do that I couldn't like
see if they're trying to Target like the
keto crowd because then it's like cheese
tomato and just but it's nasty though I
want to see that doesn't look good so
it's just cheese and
toppings cheese and toppings that looks
like um what's that thing why would I
pay for that Denver omelette if you gave
me a side of bread to dip with it I'm in
oh if it's like really cheesy you know
what I mean and then you dip it yeah
what's that thing why people do when
they get leftovers and they put it in
the oven casserole casserole that looks
like that that looks like that well
white people do that's true you know
your white history that's white fried
rice dude oh [ __ ] it is white fried rice
they just get their thing and then they
put it together the lima bean casserole
I don't know what's in it but that's
just Bob dude whatever they didn't
finish yesterday man that's what's in it
yeah so people are all kind of making
fun of it I don't know if they're
hitting their target demo that they were
intending right like who was the target
I think maybe people that are enjoying
like you know people that like
deconstrate Foods nobody likes
deconstructed Foods dude you go to you
go to Papa John's for pizza and that's
it exactly maybe Wings maybe breadsticks
because deconstructed foods are just
like the grocery store you go to a fancy
restaurant you go to like a Portland
weird like place and it'll just be like
oh it's an upside down deconstructed
Inside Out muffin or something
[Laughter]
some [ __ ] yeah what's the name of that
one I messed up
right
deconstruct oh is it like when you get a
carna like an asada plate versus tacos
or like fajitas yeah kind of in a way
sort of but that's different because
culturally they had that already oh yeah
it's not deconstructed it's an option
something would be deconstructed if it's
conventionally supposed to be together
and they're like oh look how different
it is now it's like a steak that's well
done on the inside of raw
that's impressive that is very
impressive that's an inverse yeah that's
like I would want to eat that that's
like Inception is just bleeding
everywhere how do you do that by the way
what do you how do you know I like
thinking you take a sword you you make
it real freaking hot and you go on the
inside and it Cooks how are you so
brilliant my guy blacksmith dude I'm
just sitting I'm just rubbing off a Bart
man he's like he's
sword inside and it burns it I can pull
it out a metal kebab skewer or something
it's a little bit like you don't put oil
so it gets stuck to the store when you
pull it out it gets inside out oh [ __ ]
I'm messing up that's pretty cool oh
like a sock
damn it I feel like it's a it's a kind
of a weird decision to start doing this
because you know for the most part we we
kind of look at restaurants that are
trying to be pseudo fancy and like kind
of like fake intelligent by having these
avant-garde choices on their menu that
purely are just for attention or like to
just seem different but then you you
think of Papa John's or a pizza places
like oh they're gonna stick to what
people like pizza and this is like it's
sad to see them go the route of like no
of course people aren't going to accept
this or they forget their branding like
these like these big box uh pizza places
it's like like sports games kids
birthdays or whatever right ain't no kid
wanna [ __ ] that [ __ ] crustless
pizza you think like Papa John's would
come out with like hot dogs or something
like John's you know what I mean Papa
John's your dad it's John like that
is our time oh and the hot dog comes it
comes in a brief but it's sticking out
on the side like that yeah
like boxer briefs or like suitcase boxer
briefs both both boxer breathing and
just thinking like that you know what I
mean
tastes just like Daddy sausage
that's his ideas you're the leader of
the kendras idea right there dude that
was barbell Brigade dude
yeah a meatball sub sound makes more
sense or like even a Caesar salad yes or
just something something Italian yeah
like doesn't this seem like if you
brought this to Sicily people would just
be in disgrace they would just be like
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah does that
even look objectively like no
aesthetically pleasing what are the
toppings no right it looks like a
it just looks like microwave dinners yes
but then microwave dinners are actually
good like I could have made that at home
dude yeah it honestly looks like
pre-chewed pizza wow I'm in it looks
like something you might get on an
airplane
well it's not really a compliment yeah
that that journalist or whoever try to
like put Papa John's on the spot and she
was all like you know how many calories
it's like thousands and he goes yeah
you're not supposed to eat the whole
thing it's mostly it's like because I
don't eat the whole pizza I eat like a
slice or two yeah and then she didn't
know what the [ __ ] to say and then
everyone's like wait
eats a whole [ __ ] Pizza me when I
went to college probably but it wasn't a
good decision every once in a while
every once in a while but like you know
it's not meant for that though you you
know you get like a bunch and then you
eat like a slice from like this you eat
a slice of this and you share it it's
meant to be funny or even if I eat it I
don't complain about gaining weight the
next day yeah I know what the [ __ ] I did
you know you're eating a whole pizza in
one city literally I love how the
conversation flipped it was like he was
the one telling her he's like you
calories isn't one slice
yeah it's so funny I used to eat a whole
uh so like when I was in college I and I
was just a fat [ __ ] I was eating a large
Papa John's cheese pizza uh order of
wings and a like a giant Pepsi and in
one like sesh of Call of Duty just gone
while you're playing how do you even do
it because the pizza's gonna get cold
Call of Duty as a way of like of
affecting you where every time you die
you need to do something because you're
just gonna stare at yourself dead so you
it like gives you this munchy complex
where you're like I need to feel like
I'm busy doing something so that I don't
wallow in my own shame of losing yep I
agree nice didn't mean to break that
down so educational because then you're
pacing yourself you're not ever rushing
to eat so you're never stuffed yeah so
you're just like eating chips the whole
time yeah that's why that's why I think
gamers are like hardcore games are more
prone to gaining weight because you need
some kind of like positive to like
balance out you mean the guys that are
playing like this well that too but you
know
yeah it's exactly that but yeah you're
not supposed to eat a whole Papa John's
pizza I've ever had a Papa John's Pizza
oh really yeah I like the garlic sauce
it comes with the garlic bread now
they're all I do like the garlic sauce
and I also like the fact they give you a
little pepperoncini you know what you
know what this also might be some
desperate way to like uh remove The
Branding of old Papa John's because
remember how like the racist one well
yeah but it was like pseudo ready he's
all sweaty and [ __ ] it's like they want
to like uh get rid of that old image
maybe they're just trying to [ __ ]
themselves into some other Zone he was
getting in trouble he was getting
canceled and then he was like making a
press conference and he's all sweaty the
owner Papa really yeah dude you guys
ever see that he's all sweaty and red he
like says he like says something racial
or something like that he's rapping he
made the pizza in His image yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then his own board and
Company had to ask him so he had to
resign oh really they pulled some kind
of weird [ __ ] on him where they were
doing a racial sensitivity talk and then
in that private conversation he had said
the n-word as a reference to things you
shouldn't say and then they the person
talking to them relayed that out and
said like oh papa John said that N word
and that was it it's [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up man yeah I mean he looks at it
as a way of like they were trying to
oust him because they wanted complete
control of the shares which sounds more
realistic it does sound realistic so
then he was removed from there and the
next thing you know Shaq's on the box
and because Shaq took over the company
no he didn't take it over but then he
was the next face on the box because you
know it used to be Papa John's actual
face and people felt like connected it's
a pizza thing owned by a real guy but he
also is known to own a lot of franchises
and he's a master businessman so I'm
like yeah
right and then there was like a thing
where like a big conglomerate like
acquired a portion of Papa John's and
they were just ousting him slowly and
then eventually they that's that's the
tail at least I mean that happens all
the time corporate takeovers yeah sure
yeah when was your guys's first time
like because back in the day it was like
you had Little Caesars dominoes and
Pizza Hut right and I think Papa John's
was everyone's first gourmet pizza when
they ate that they're like what the [ __ ]
is this the way they branded it it was
like Gourmet and it tastes different but
it's a fall from grace though it's
different from dominoes dude it's very
different it's it's not seen like I just
hope there's like some legit Italians
watching us call Papa John's Gourmet
Pizza hey but when you're when you're 12
years old Italians bro round table when
you're 12 years old though that [ __ ] is
like next level you think his ass when I
was a kid Round Table is ass bro like I
wet I want went back and it was just
like it was so ah did you eat inside did
you eat inside with the arcade and the
and the pictures of soda we got a whole
pizza and they and it came in different
like each slice was different shapes but
sometimes you gotta you gotta you gotta
mix and match
pizza because they were just angry doing
this [ __ ] Right Round Table Pizza is Mom
Celeste with an extra layer of cheese
shut up bro take that back right now you
know what's funny I once uh tweeted I
like back when like Twitter was the [ __ ]
for me I tweeted that I uh ordered Papa
John's and that it was like bad and then
Round Table tweeted me back and they
were like anytime you're ordering a
different Pizza we'll send you free
coupons from Round Table and I was like
I'm good
[Laughter]
foreign